[Music]  I've just been told that someone who's  originally from the Chicago area  desperately wants to stop by to tell me  how much he has enjoyed our week in  Chicago please welcome one of the stars  at the hilarious show parks and  recreation Nick Offerman  [Music]  [Applause]  Nik I just have to thank you so much for  stopping by rakonin I think I speak for  all of Chicago when I say I can hardly  contain my giddy excitement at merely  being in your electrifying presence I'm  experiencing an adrenaline rush that  Olympic skiers and bullfighters can only  dream of  really cuz to be honest Nick you don't  seem too excited  make no mistake Conan waves of pure joy  are washing over me like a child  experiencing his first Christmas morning  and I'm consumed with a rhapsodic  delight the likes of which I've never  known  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  I'd feel better I really do